[Musique]
oui bien d'apparaître comme si ces
milices au moulin de ping est venu en
2022 une nouvelle chronique nouveau
moment mais bien sûr ça va être un truc
comme l'effet des dernières années on
dirait qu'on recommence à nouvelle année
chaque fois avec 2020 2021 eh bien ça va
être la même sur deux cuisantes
autochtones parce qu'il ya des enjeux
qui n'ont pas été réglés ce soit la
problématique de la protection des
langues autochtones d'ailleurs 2022
grande décennie qui commence sur les
langues autochtones on va parler aussi
du racisme mais je dois parler de
beaucoup d'enjeux qui vont venir au
quotidien toucher les communautés
autochtones et on commence l'année enfin
parce que on a une annonce de 20
milliards de dollars 20 milliards
millions 20 milliards de dollars ce qui
est un chiffre quand même assez
astronomiques pour
compenser les enfants qui sont passés à
travers le système des services sociaux
donc les gens au long des réactions
aussi mitigé il faut des réactions très
joyeuse pourquoi mitigé joyeuse parce
qu'il ya une incompréhension de pourquoi
maintenant c'est cet argent là pour ses
enfants il y est je pense que vous avez
dû remarquer au cours des dernières deux
dernières décennies qui a eu beaucoup de
compensation monétaire pour les
politiques canadiennes et leurs effets
sur des communautés autochtones et cette
nouvelle annonce n'est que la suite le
deux minots de toutes les autres
compensations qui ont été faites pour
des politiques canadiennes donc on va
penser au pensionnat on va penser à la
rafle des années 60 aux écoles de jour
et aujourd'hui justement les enfants qui
sont passés à travers le système des
services sociaux pourquoi pas ce sont
des politiques qui ont été mis en place
et ses politiques n'ont eu non seulement
des effets dévastatrices sur les
communautés autochtones sur les liens
familiaux mais aussi sur le sentiment de
sécurité et le sentiment d'ailleurs
qu'une
pratique de racisme qui existent berra
systémique dans les services qui sont
offerts si on est autochtone et le
j'ouvre une boîte de pandore chance on
est plusieurs à l'avoir ouvert l'arrière
pourquoi est ce que c'est une
problématique parce que les services
sociaux on se posait d'interdît la dpj
l'ailé les fouilles à qu'elles sont là
pour aider les enfants mais par le passé
et encore aujourd'hui malheureusement
ces systèmes love
ce service là étaient souvent un service
soit punitif service qui a été
déconnecté justement des réalités non
seulement culturelle mais familial aussi
des communautés autochtones ont refusé
de placer des enfants qui auraient pu
être placés dans des familles
directement dans des familles proches
grands parents oncles tantes parce que
justement selon la liste des services ça
ne représentait pas les standards mais
ces trésors pour une communauté
autochtone de représenter des stands
heures quand justement on connaît toutes
les pratiques de sous financement par
rapport aux maisons par rapport aux
services et aussi au grand nombre des
familles qui vivent dans des fois une
maison est ce ça ne veut pas dire que la
maison est insécure ça ne veut pas dire
que la maison n'a pas de l'amour c'est
juste qu'on a mis on a forcé un un
système sur les communautés qui ne
pouvait pas mettre à jour les maisons
des foyers aux standards non autochtone
et ça le fait que beaucoup d'enfants ont
été envoyés dans les villes loin des
communautés ont été détachés de leurs
familles détacher de leur langue leur
culture on peut plus être accueillis
justement dans leur nom dans leurs
cercles proches
les fesses et la perte de la langue la
paire de la culture 1
comment je suis un musulman aussi
culturelle mais non seulement culturel
mais aussi raciale folle ou pour
l'oublier pour beaucoup de gens le
racisme ça n'existe pas mais pour
beaucoup d'autochtones de personnes
assises et c'est une réalité quotidienne
donc même si on veut
ne pas oublier ça ça risque d'être
autochtone est seul au centre de une
communauté qui ne nous représentent pas
il ya un détachement ailleurs une
sentiment d'isolement et il ya des
situations qui peuvent être assez
perturbatrice pour un jeune enfant dont
les effets de ces années là vont être
compensés au chiffre de 40 mille dollars
par enfant ils ont entendu beaucoup de
commentaires roy c'est généreux aussi
bien si ce n'est pas généreux ce n'est
pas bien c'est la compensation c'est à
dire que on élève un chiffre haut niveau
un chiffre vraiment au niveau de ce que
l'on pense pour compenser les effets
dévastateurs de leur enfance je dis pas
que tous les services sociaux sont
mauvais il faut vraiment comprendre
qu'on parle de ceux qui ont eu des
effets négatifs ceux qui ont eu des
détachements familia faut comprendre que
c'est pas tout le monde qui est égal il
ya des services sociaux qui sont
nécessaires dans les communautés mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut qu'on sait
services sociaux le soin aussi inhumains
ou détachés des réalités des communautés
autochtones ou même causé plus de tort
que de bien donc faut pas qu'on peut pas
confondre le manque de besoin on a un
besoin pour des services sociaux
adéquats mais il faut voir comment les
services sociaux ont été mis en place
dans les dernières décennies et pourquoi
on compense ses enfants et si on devait
vous compenser pour les effets justement
d'avoir été arrachés votre service ces
détachements leur qui existent et qui
donne un des impacts de la colonisation
et justement
la forme du système qui est raciste
40000 de l'or est ce un chiffre
suffisant donc en espérant que cela peut
donner un coup de main aux enfants en
espérant aussi que les services adéquats
sont nécessaires aux jeunes où survient
à ceux qui sont devenus de jeunes
adultes sont sortis du système justement
des foyers d'accueil vont être aussi
financé parce qu'il ya une compensation
qui est nécessaire comme si quelqu'un
vous vous faire peur et qu'on vous
compense pour se tord le tout le monde
peut avoir ce genre de justice ne soit
c'est une chose mais ensuite est ce que
le système va pouvoir aussi faire en
sorte que le filet social qui est
nécessaire pour défaire toutes ces
décennies la de problématique soit aussi
financier c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'il faut garder à l'oeil comme j'aime
poussée des black stars c'est encore sur
papier faut voir comment ces montants là
vont être mis en action il faut garder à
l'oeil aussi qu'il y à des réalités qui
n'existait pas dans la tête des
gouvernements il ya pas si longtemps se
dire qu'ils ont une réalité quand et des
communautés autochtones dans les
communautés ce qu'on appelle les
réserves où les communautés à
l'extérieur des milieux urbains et une
nouvelle population en milieu urbain les
grandes centres qui existent et qui
justement tous ces jeunes qui ont été
envoyés dans les foyers d'accueil des
fois se retrouve dans le système urbain
et ont besoin de services adéquats et
appropriée donc on va voir comment le
financement autour des communautés le
financement autour des services qui sont
nécessaires en milieu urbain va être
fait donc il faut vraiment avoir un
équilibre qui va se créer dans cette
réalité le jeu ne peut pas être ignorée
et aussi il va falloir qu'on parle de la
discussion qui va s'en tenir sur le
retour culturel de beaucoup de jeunes
parce qu'ils vont être souvent confondue
justement avec une une réappropriation
culturelle et ne pas confondre avec
l'appropriation peter r on parle d'une
réappropriation donc leur culture qui
leur étaient arrachés enlevé par
justement ces placements force et la
houle par le système qui les a amenés
vers ça et qui ne leur a pas fourni leur
identité culturelle et comment le mot
pour se reconnecter versus les gens qui
vont peut-être aller faire de
l'appropriation culturelle et 10 rebonds
mais c'est une connexion qui existent
pour tout le monde il faut vraiment on
va avoir des discussions à plusieurs
niveaux et avec 20 milliards de dollars
vous pouvez imaginer aussi que ça va
faire venir des gens qui des fois ne
sont pas docteur n'ont pas cette réalité
là lié à cet historique là mais l'argent
peut aussi des fois faire sortir on dit
les jours sourit les placards
donc tout ça va amener un très grosse
discussion des choses qui vont venir
dans les prochaines années et qui vont
ensuite engrangé vers une réconciliation
qu'on espère pouvoir
dire qu'ils réel qui est enclenché et
qui va guérir des communautés qui va
leur permettre justement de revenir un
homme de vie qui est adéquat pour
n'importe quel manque de la population
canadienne et ça c'est très important de
voir comment
ce regain culturel ce regain
linguistique là est important pour tous
les goûts toutes les personnes qui sont
sorties du système je vais aussi c'est
important pour les québécois de garder
la langue française
historiquement imaginer ce que c'est
pour des enfants qu'ils parlaient qui ne
le parle plus à cause qui sont passés à
travers les pensionnats donc toutes ces
réalités ne vont être connectés avec les
autres enjeux qui existe dans la rue
comme je voudrais ici autochtones le
grand panier autochtone du canada et
vous pouvez manger un bandit chronique à
raconter autour de ça et qu'on va
essayer de démêler
cette grosse boule de noeux biologique
de ces discussions qui n'ont pas encore
apparu sur la place publique le fait de
voir des gens qui ont des opinions
dessus et qui n'ont pas la réalité
justement des communautés autochtones
des gens qui sont la réalité autochtone
et qui veulent regagner revivre
justement cette connexion là avec leur
culture parce qu'il ya un aspect
communautaire revivre des fois une
connexion avec la famille parce que des
fois il ya une distance qui a été fait
justement entre les familles et le jeune
homme en mai les familles veulent
pouvoir ré accueillir la personne qui a
été envoyée justement au foyer d'accueil
il ya toutes ces enjeux là et vous
pouvez imaginer que c'est un enjeu de
coeur et c'est un enjeu qui va toucher
beaucoup l'imaginaire canadien donc vous
risquez d entendre parler dans les
prochaines années
je suis soufflé jeu son travail que
toutes les personnes qui vont être
impliqués là-dedans vont avoir à faire
mais quand même les meilleurs pour
commencer justement à réparer parce que
c'est monétaire s'est pas l'action de la
réparation faut pas oublier que beaucoup
de gens qui ont reçu des réparations
monétaire pour les pensionnats pour la
star de 1068 aussi pour les écoles de
jour c'est pas sur le montant d'argent
qu'ils ont réussi à se guérir c'est
surtout l'accueil l'ouverture
l'amour qui a été donnée envers les
personnes et le fait qu'on les offres
écouter et entendre
alors jours c'est un bon début d'année
et n'hésitez pas envoyez des questions
n'hésitez pas surtout à partager notre
chronique on travaille très fort pour
pouvoir essayer de démystifier les
enjeux de les les les rentes dit
j'estime parce que des fois c'est des
montagnes se présentent à nous et ça
c'est parce que ça fait des décennies
que ça aurait dû être discutée cdd syli
de réalité qui n'ont pas encore été mis
sur la table des canadiens et des
québécois donc n'hésitez pas à les
partager s'était pas en discuter mais
surtout visiter pas à écouter la
population autochtone est ce qu'elle a à
partager bonne semaine